interesting article this week in The
Wall Street Journal workers get a faster
access to wages with new apps instant
pay helps boost employee attendance but
can make savings harder to do I don't
know if you knew this or not but people
like uber that was the first place I saw
it you can get paid every day when you
finish doing your uber runs every day
you click on the app on the uber app and
it pays you right then that's a pretty
cool thing actually set Dave to himself
when he first heard that which I do
think it's a cool thing I did not think
about it much as being a dangerous thing
because I thought well that's extra pay
it's extra work you're doing to get out
of debt you know that's fine because I
tell we advertise for uber for drivers
right and I'm thinking that's a good
idea so the article reads like this for
more workers across America every day is
payday
uber Technologies Inc McDonald's Corp
and bloomin brands inks Outback steak
houses are among the many growing group
of employers giving workers near instant
access to their wages through payday
apps new tools that allow people to
spend the money they just earned that
provided some workers an alternative to
short-term high interest loans
say the technology startups offering the
services see I think that's just bull
it's not an alternative it is for some
people I mean if you're really really
broke and you're you know you're dealing
with payday lenders and you're doing
that kind of stuff yeah this could keep
you from doing that but that wasn't what
I thought of when I saw it I thought you
get the money faster so you could pay it
on your debt faster that's what I
thought out and a lot of people working
over a lot of people working stuff like
McDonald's or Outback Steakhouse are
that's their second job I mean I would I
would wager to say most of them it's
their second job so you don't find any
traditional 40-hour workweek companies
hardly doing this early pay but pay by
the day thing but it's contract work or
it's a second job contract hours
contract work you know
so you know and and so employers across
the retail restaurant and service
sectors are searching for inexpensive
perks to attract and hold on to
employees in the face of low
unemployment for workers immediate
access to cash can provide liquidity to
cover emergency costs but economists say
it is unclear whether smaller more
frequent paychecks will help us
households that are under financial
strain well what kind of an economist
argue if you can't figure that out I
mean that's just dumber than rock listen
if your pay is low and you take your low
pay once a day or you take it once a
month you still have low pay you know
need an economist to figure that out
there financial strain is not caused by
all from their paychecks come their
financial strain it's it's caused by
their obey and their high expenditures
you don't economist to figure this out
oh my goodness it's almost like a drug
for employees says ed Shaw the executive
vice president of human resources for
Casper's company which operates 54
McDonald's restaurants in Florida
roughly 1,300 of the franchises at
franchise
workers have signed up to use a
smartphone app instant financial since
Casper's began testing in April workers
have quickly taken to the service mr.
Shaw says it's demonstrated by the waves
of angry phone calls they received from
workers on the few occasions that the
app experienced a glitch every day at
10:00 a.m. the app notifies users on how
much they are in the previous workday
prompting them to decide if they want to
deposit as much as half of that money
into a debit card roughly 20% of
employees accept the money every day
says mr. Shaw who has refused reviewed
the aggregate usage data instant
financial costs employees nothing to use
and instead charges the business owners
a fee to operate the money disbursement
service other apps have a revenue model
that heats as much as three dollars from
a workers daily paycheck
now let me tell you that's a bad deal if
you have a daily paycheck that's low
when you get three dollars out of it
that could be I could be ten percent a
day I mean that could be ridiculous so
daily payments could help some workers
smooth out the financial volatility of a
fluctuating work schedule many Americans
remain on shaky financial footing with
little to no savings eight years after
the recessions end that prompts some 12
million consumers to take out payday
loans each year let's see that's just a
bunch of crap okay
yes there are many Americans that are
struggling yes there are still some
people that don't earn like they should
be earning but the thing that prompts 12
million consumers to take out payday
loans is not the fact that they're all
broke for because of their how often
they get a paycheck you know they may be
broke because they don't get them
paycheck much and they may be broke
because they mishandle the money but the
number of people that use payday lenders
just because of the recession from eight
ten years ago come on no you're not
handling money and or you're not making
enough money and both are hard to do
granted but I mean we're not gonna give
you an excuse to go that prompts your
things are bad so they use payday
lenders no they use payday lenders so
things are bad hello and fixing how
often someone is paid does not fix that
so there's a premise running through
this whole article that the poor poor
poor working man can't make it and so
this daily pay app is going to help him
and you know he can't make it otherwise
cuz how often he's paid is his problem
no that's a bunch of crap okay listen
there's two sides of the equation the
income side and the outgo side you got
to work on both sides all the time you
gotta get you income up and here I'll go
down all the time then how often you're
paid doesn't affect that okay that
doesn't run you into a payday lender
that doesn't do all this other stuff
however that does not make me against a
daily payout I don't mind the daily
payout unless you're just managing it
you know it's like beer money for the
day and I'm gonna go drinking every
night right I gotta get my beer money so
I'm
hit my payday app and go out every night
you know and I have no money because I'm
drunk all the time
I mean seriously there's people that do
this stuff I have heard I actually know
a few so there you go
and let's see Dean wormer from Animal
House you can't live your life drunken
stupid son you know but but you know so
there's some of that going on here and I
would not suggest you use your payday
you know you're you're early pay app or
your payday app to get paid every day to
do any of that what I would tell you to
do is use it when it's your extra job to
pay quickly more quickly onto your debts
and more often on your debts and maybe
you don't have to hit it every day but
you can you can control when you get
paid and I like that feature of it I
think that's nice if the feature is
allowing you to misbehave with money
then that's a bad idea
so 30 some odd years ago I owned some
low income rental property that we
collected the rent every Friday
afternoon weekly rental and we got 25 to
30% more for those rental properties
then we would have renting the same
house monthly but these were folk they
could not make their money make it
through the weekend
because of their personal behavior
patterns let's see that's your thing
your personal behavior patterns affect
you caused you to pay too much cause you
waste money so beware of these apps
unless you're using them properly hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh